foreign
looks like there's firearms in it
[Music]
I know but unfortunately there's certain
procedures we have to follow anytime
something comes in that's prohibited
correct right so listen you understand
that correct
if you have your ID on you sorry my ID's
in my bag in the bag yes I'm a monster
service I'm a minor sir I have security
guards they left that in my bag sir I
had to knock my bag
after the fact okay until then I have to
put you in handcuffs until we figure
this out okay okay
[Music]
we'll we'll do that after okay all right
just turn around for me be cooperative
every
video and audio surveillance plus I'm on
body cam you understand that I
understand okay
I'm just this is just for your safety
and everybody else around you because
there's guns involved okay or a possible
gun we have to confirm it okay x-ray
doesn't tell us 100 okay just as there's
a possibility and that's what it appears
to be you understand do you have
anything else on you at this point
okay
I understand
do you have a concealed weapons permit
or anything like that no sir they left
that in my bag my little brothers are
outside waiting for me sir
I promise you so that's not mine
I have security guard sir okay see how
much jewelry I have on me listen
that's okay if you got that the problem
is it's bringing it into the truck just
have a seat for me just have a seat I
would never do that sir
I'm a good kid man I'm not saying you're
bad but have I mistreated you or
anything okay not at all sir I'm just
trying to tell you sir but you
understand the severity of what is
occurring right I would never do this I
fly every week dude listen
if what you're telling me is true we can
work things out okay
but there's procedures we have to follow
uh but it looks like probably possibly
two guns and a few mags he's saying that
he's an actor and he has private
security guards does he have three
weapons permission no no he doesn't have
uh
his ID and everything's supposedly in
the bags
I fly every week sir
I'm gonna rush into the airport I have a
Premiere I'm an actor that's why I have
a big change but this have a TV
show oh sir this will ruin my life you
have a concealed weapons